[Musique]
comme chaque année depuis sa création en
août 2000 20 l'observatoire
départemental de la protection de
l'enfance de la réunion s'est réunie en
comité plénier ce mardi 23 août 2022
dans l'hémicycle du palais de la source
une quarantaine de partenaires
institutionnels et associatifs notamment
la sous préfète en charge de la cohésion
sociale et de la jeunesse madame camille
dagorn ont répondu présent à
l'invitation du conseil départemental
l'observatoire départemental de
protection de l'enfance est un
outil de travail qui permet aux
opérateurs de travailler ensemble de
coordonner leurs actions nous mêmes
départements bien évidemment préfecture
de la réunion et divers partenaires
comme l'éducation nationale les
autorités judiciaires social et
administratif
quand il s'agit de protéger l'enfant
réunionnais nous devons être
volontariste il s'agit de l'avenir même
de la réunion à l'ordre du jour ce mardi
la présentation du rapport d'exécution
2022 l'occasion de faire le bilan des
actions menées pendant l'année écoulée
mais surtout de dérouler les
perspectives de l'eau dpe pour cette
année c'est la deuxième année que nous
travaillons au sein de cet observatoire
et au fur et à mesure que nous allons
penser nous allons intégrer d'autres
problématiques notamment liée au fait
que nous devons aussi faire en sorte que
tout ce qui touche à l'accueil à
l'hébergement des enfants en difficulté
soit renforcé et là le département est
en train de recruter par exemple des
familles d'accueil pour pouvoir
justement et lancia l'offre d'accueil
des enfants en difficulté des places
pour les fratries beaucoup plus
nombreuses seront créés en établissement
et dans diverses institutions dans la
continuité des travaux de l'eau dpe le
département qu organisera avec le réseau
idéal qu les prochaines rencontres
territoriales de la protection de
l'enfance en outre mer qui se tiendront
les 30 novembre et 1er décembre prochain
[Musique]
non